.
YEAH OF THE MAIN. HOWEVER IT
WOULD BE COPY. I'M SORRY YEAH
ONE. VERY GOOD. YEAH THERE'S A
LOT OF YEAH. THOUGHT THERE WAS
NO LONGER. YOU'RE NOT. YEAH I
GOT. WORKING REQUIRE SOCIAL TO
NJ MONTHS. TO START YOU KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE. USER YEAH THIS
IS OUR- RIGHT YEAH YEAH. RIGHT
THERE PROGRAM. OKAY GIVE FOR
ITS- YEAH. ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
UHHUH
WHAT WHATEVER HAPPENS ON. YEAH
PERFECT. THIRTEEN SIX. AT SIX
FORTY FIVE. TWO OF. OKAY. YEAH
YEAH. YEAH. UHHUH. FIVE YEAH.
RIGHT RIGHT HOW EXACTLY YEAH.
YEAH THE OWNER OF THE- WHAT'S
WRONG. YEAH ARE YOU ARE NEED
KNOW TRY TO TAKE TIME NOT.
ALMOST YES. BUT NOT SO. THANK.
OKAY TWO HUNDRED OKAY. REALLY
REALLY HELPFUL. THAT'S WHAT
YEAH. YEAH. OKAY. YEAH THANK
YOU. FIVE OKAY. GREAT. THERE WE.
YEAH. YEAH. UHHUH UHHUH. UHHUH
UHHUH. HELLO. SO. YEAH. OKAY
I'M- THE FORMER. OKAY YEAH YEAH
YEAH. OKAY UHHUH. OKAY. GARTH.
YEAH. BUT RIGHT RIGHT. YEAH
UHHUH. FOUR FOR. MY
SUBSTITUTABLE. OKAY. ONE THAT'S
GOING TO FOR A LONG YEAH. MANY
YEAH SO I DON'T HAVE A POLICY.
RIGHT RIGHT. YEAH. ONE YEAH.
GET A PLACE ENTER ARE SOME.
YEAH WE HAVE A WE YEAH. WE ARE.
OKAY. EXAMPLES CORY. ONE NOW
OKAY ONE WORKING. ONE SILENCE.
HE'S SPEAKS JACKSONVILLE WE ARE.
BY THE TIME IT'S RIGHT FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE. GROUNDS FOR
WELL ON THIS THAT'S WHAT THE
SERVICE WAS. ROCKET MAN. THERE
ARE ONE IS AT HIGHER OVER THERE.
YOUR FINDS THIS IS FAMILY.
PARDON BECAUSE IT WAS. YEAH
HOLD. OKAY. WORLD CHAMPION.
OKAY I WAS HERE. YEAH ONE
SISTER. OKAY. ONE OF THE BUT
YOU SO SUPPOSEDLY. UHHUH BUT AS
FAR AS THAT WILL ONLY BE. YEAH
SURVEY FOUND. YEAH HI I. I'M
HERE THREE. ARE HOSPITAL. I
DON'T. WHAT. ONE THAT. WOULD BE
A- OKAY. YEAH. I THOUGHT IT WAS
OKAY I THINK. IN YEAH. YEAH I
THANK YOU BECAUSE I. YES IS SO
WITH THIS HAVE. SO STILL HAVE
SOMEONE FROM. IT FOR THOSE FIVE
ABOUT FIVE TO SEVEN YES WE'RE
GONNA LOOK FIVE. HE YOU CAN
THEY'LL HAVE THE- APPLE HERE.
RIGHT. BECAUSE OF RIGHT YEAH
THEY'RE NOT. YEAH ON THE DAY SO
HERE'S.
SIX JOHN. AT ZERO ZERO
OR SOMETHING YEAH BUT THIS. YOU
CAN STILL GO HIM. FIRST. UHHUH
OKAY. UHHUH. IN THE MIDDLE. ON
THE BRIGHT SIDE OF THINGS.
UHHUH. YEAH YEAH SO THAT'S-
UHHUH. UHHUH YEAH. 334-567-8910
TESTING. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE. IF YOU PREFER THE
PROVINCE. THERE MILLIE'S. YEAH.
TESTING. 1-234-567-8910 TESTING
ONE TWO THREE FOUR. IF YOU
WERE. CALLING ABOUT. YEAH UHHUH
YEAH. OKAY REALLY. THANK YOU
FOR. RIGHT YEAH. YEAH IS THERE
ANYTHING. OKAY SIR IS IF YOU
HAVE A. EVERYTHING. UHHUH. OKAY.
YEAH HALEY YEAH I DON'T KNOW.
EXACTLY. UHHUH OKAY. YEAH YEAH
JUST TO MAKE SURE. UHHUH. UHHUH.
UHHUH.
RIGHT YEAH.
WARNING. HELLO YEAH. WELL RIGHT.
UHHUH. UHHUH. THERE. THE DATA.
UHHUH.
YEAH UHHUH. UHHUH OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON. TODAY I WANT TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON OUR
RESPONSE TO THE CHINA VIRUS.
AND WHAT MY ADMINISTRATOR
SUNBELT SEEMS LARGELY IN SUN
BELT BUT COULD BE SPREADING MY
TEAM IS ALSO WORKING NIGHT AND
DAY WITH CAPITOL HILL TO
ADVANCED XP COULD NOT MAKE
RELIEF PACKAGE WORKING HARD ON
IT WOULD MAKE A PRESS SAY ALSO.
WE'LL TRY GET A- WHAT IT FACE
FOR IT WILL GO TO GET IT AND
WILL PROTECT OUR WORKERS OUR
SCHOOLS OUR FAMILIES AND
PROTECTIVE VERY STRONGLY. AS
ONE FAMILY MOURNED EVERY
PRECIOUS LIFE THAT'S BEEN LOST
I PLEDGES THEIR HONOR THAT WE
DEVELOP A VACCINE. AND WE WILL
DEFEAT THE VIRUS WERE DOING
VERY WELL WITH VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT AND THERAPEUTIC
DEVELOPMENT. BUT I WANT TO. THE
JOB THEY DO IS INCREDIBLE AND
THEY ACTUALLY BRAVE.
ADMINISTRATION WILL STOP AT
NOTHING TO SAVE LIVES AND
SHIELD OF ALDER YOUR SUPPORT.
WITH SO MUCH ABOUT THE DISEASE.
AND WE HAVE ALL UP AND WE ARE
GOING TO INDEED SHE'LL. AND
AGAIN THE VACCINES ARE CUT IN
THE COMING A LOT SOONER THAN
ANYONE THOUGHT POSSIBLE BY
YEARS IF YOU LOOK AT THE OLD
SYSTEM AND LOOK AT THE NURSES
LANDING YOU. WEEVIL A GREAT.
WHO WOULD TARGET. WE ARE A
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A
STRATEGY THAT'S GOING TO BE
VERY VERY POWERFUL WE DEVELOP
AS WE GO ALONG SO ABOUT COUNTRY
I'M VERY WELL OTHERS ARE DOING
LESS WELL. IT WILL PROBABLY
ONLY GET. BETTER SOMETHING I
DON'T LIKE SAYING ABOUT THINGS
BUT THAT'S THE WAY IT IS IT'S
THE WAITING THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
TO GO THE WORLD SORT. SAID
EVERYTHING THEY- NEED THEY GET.
AND WE ARE IN GOOD CARE WE HAVE
TRUMP SUPPLIES AND A GREAT
SUPPLY CHAIN. WILL SPEND. YEAH
OUT JUST. NEED SO THAT'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE FROM. PARROTING VERY
VERY EMPTY. THE MEDIAN AGE OF
THOSE WHO SUCCUMB TO THE CHINA
VIRUSES EIGHT ZERO. ROUGHLY
THAT SEVEN INDIVIDUALS IN
NURSING HOMES OR LONG TERM CARE.
IN ONE STUDY 90% OF THOSE
HOSPITALIZED HAD UNDERLYING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS. WHAT ARE
YOUR DIABETES BUT USUALLY IT'S-
SOME KIND OF A CONDITION IT
SEEMS THAT PEOPLE HAVE THAT AND
THEY DO IT SUPPORT QUESTION
ABOUT. ADULTS MAY ALL HAVE.
EVEN NO. A WARNING CHECK. THEY
WON'T HAVE ANY IDEA THEY HAVE
WIRES THEY WILL HAVE ANY IDEA
AT ALL. ERIC IS YOUTH WILL ACT
RESPONSIBLY RISK. ACTUALLY
DISTANCE WHERE OF GET A MASK-
WHETHER YOU LIKE THE MASK OR
NOT. HAVE AN IMPACT IT WILL
HAVE AN EFFECT AND WE NEED
EVERY CAN GET. THAT SHOWS
CHILDREN AT THE LOWER PAID TO
SCAN BE NOT POINT SIX FIRST.
ALL RIGHT. FIGURE IT. THAT MUCH
MUCH LESS THAN 1% FOR CHILDREN.
ALL JUSTIN THESE REP PROFILES
AND- HOW TO TREAT THE DISEASE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GREATLY
REDUCE MORTALITY IT ADDED
STATE'S APPROACH. WHAT CHART
AND- WE DO COMPARED TO THE REST
OF THE WORLD WE HAVE SEVERAL
TREATMENTS ALREADY AVAILABLE A
DIFFICULT IS THE SEVEN THIRTY.
WHICH IS CECIL IN A WIDELY
AVAILABLE STEROID TREATMENT AND
WE HAVE MANY MORE HAPPENING IN
COMING OUT YOU'VE LEARNED. BEST
TO TREATMENT OF THE VIRUS AT
EVERY. ENTER HERE THESE
FINDINGS MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND
WE SHARE THE MALL THE WORLD.
RELATIONSHIP WITH COUNTRIES HAS
BEEN. WORKING TOGETHER THIS
INCLUDES IN ALL HOSPITALS ARE
AWARE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIFFERENT APPROACH. HI FLOW
OXYGEN IMPORTANCE OF STEROID
TREATMENT FOR THOSE ON
VENTILATORS. AND WHEN YOU'RE ON
A VENTILATOR- WE'VE LEARNED
FROM THIS ABOUT THE U. THE
VENTILATOR. UNDEAD BE ABLE. IT
EXPIRE LIKE THIS WHERE WE
NEEDED SOME AND LATER SO FAST
THAT EVEN THE USE OF THE RENTAL
DOCTORS HAVE BECOME. THE END.
HELP IT BECOME IN. GOOD IT
WHICH IS ACTUALLY VERY
COMPLICATED PROCEDURE AND
ALLOCATE SEVERE TO HOSPITALS
BASED ON NEW ADMISSIONS SINCE
IT WORKS BEST. THEY SHOULD AND
THAT'S EARLIER FATALITIES
NATIONWIDE OF FALLEN 75% SINCE
MID APRIL NUMBER AS K. STERN
FACE FELONIES RISE IN CERTAIN
HARD STATE WILL. RIGHT NOW.
PERSONAL FLIES IN THERAPY WE
AGAIN HAVE. SIMPSON HAS. IN
VERY GOOD SHAPE CAN MOVE THEM
QUICKLY OUR CASE FATALITY RATE
HAS CONTINUED TO DECLINE AND IS
LOWER THAN THE EUROPEAN UNION
AND ALMOST EVERYWHERE ELSE IN
THE WORLD. AMERICAN TOP THE
UNITED ANDREW. WELL THE WORLD
IS SUFFERING VERY BADLY. ACT IS
THAT MANY CUT THIS. ARE
SUFFERING VERY VERY BADLY AND
THEY'VE BEEN SUFFERING FROM
THIS VIRUS FOR A LONG TIME.
WE'VE DONE MUCH BETTER THAN THE
FATALITY RATE AT A- LOWER RATE
THAN MOST. WE'RE WORKING
AGAINST THEM BECAUSE WE'RE
HELPING A LOT OF COUNTRY IS
THAT EVEN THOUGH ABOUT IT ALL
THE TIME IN FOR HELP. LATER
THEY HAVE TO GET HIM THEY'RE
VERY HARD TO GET. WE'LL MAKE IT
I WAS. DOZENS OF VENTILATORS A
MONTHS IT'S BEEN QUITE AMAZING
WE- KEEP DOING JOB AND THINGS
WILL. BETTER THERE WILL BE
PUTTING UP JOE. MAY SHOWING A
DIFFERENT STATISTICS ARE
DIFFERENT REP SUCCESSOR SHE
COULD SAY ALSO THE THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO BETTER ON. BUT YOU'RE-
OKAY L. IN APRIL THE AVERAGE.
OVER FIFTY YEARS OLD TODAY THE
AVERAGE AGE IS SIGNIFICANT
YOUNGER HOSPITAL LENGTHS OF
STAY ARE ALMOST HALF OF WHAT
THEY WERE UNABLE. THE STAYS
ABOUT F. RADIO K. REQUIRE.
GRETCHEN IT'S BEEN REDUCED IN
MORTALITY IN IS A BIT. SLOW IS
NEAR. IN A WE'VE LEARNED A LOT
WE'RE A LOT OF THIS DISEASE HAD
A HAMLET THAT IS OF LEARNED A
LOT. HAPPENING TO LIKELY. AND
OTHER ELEMENTS STEROIDS AT
CENTER BUT THESE TRENDS COULD
CHANGE WITHOUT OUR CONTINUED
RELENTLESS THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
WILL LEAD OKAY THAT WAY FROM
THE BEGINNING BUT WE LEARNED
MUCH YOU KNOW WHAT IN A- THE
RISING. PRIMARILY AMONG
EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY FIVE YEAR
OLDS MANY OF THE WERE TIM ALSO
FACE THE CHALLENGE OF A STICK
IN SPICING VIRUS CASES- YOUR
BEST OF STERN. INCLUDING RIGHT
ADDRESS BENNETT. A GENTLEMAN
WAS HERE TWO WEEKS AGO AND THEY
HAVE REALLY BEEN HIT HARD.
BECAUSE SHE LIVED A FULL BOLD
INCREASE IN TESTING CAPACITY TO
ME THAT'S WHERE SUCCESS THE
IDEA THANK. A SIMPLE. OKAY OKAY
SO MILD THAT YOU REALLY DON'T
THREE SOME CASES- WITH CHILDREN
WHERE IN THE KNOW THAT THE REAL.
I GUESS A VERY ILL BECAUSE THEY
RECOVER. OKAY S. IS CONDUCTING.
WE'RE TESTING YOU WE'VE
CONDUCTED THREE JOBS AS MANY
TESTS AS ALL OF THE OTHER
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD YOUR
HEMISPHERE COMBINED THE OVER
FIFTY MILLION TO. SYMPTOMS SO
WE NOTICED WHEN IT'S GOING TO
BE THERE WE'RE ALSO WORKING TO
REDUCE TURNAROUND MY
ADMINISTRATION BEEN
AGGRESSIVELY FUNDING IS. IN THE
SUN BELT AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
SO WORKING VERY CLOSE WITH ALL
GOLFERS BUT RIGHT NOW IN
PARTICULAR THOSE GOT.
COORDINATING WITH THOSE IN THE
IN THE THREE SAID CENTS SENIOR
FOR. IT H. WITH GOVERNOR
PROVIDE RECOMMENDED THINGS TO
VERY LEADERS DATE INCLUDING
HOSPITAL ADMINISTRATORS
INCEPTION MY ADMINISTRATION
CORRECTLY HAS ZERO UNVEILED
REQUIRE US OR FULL BILL REQUEST.
EQUIPMENT OR ANY POSTED FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S NOW GONE NEEDS
ANYTHING RIGHT NOW WHEN WE
THINK WE'LL HAVE A- OVER THE
FRANK WE ARE IN STOCK. AFTER WE
ONLY THOUSD NATIONAL GUARD
AND MILITARY MEDICAL PERSONAL
IN TEXAS CALIFORNIA FLORIDA AND
ARIZONA THAT'S HELPING LEE I
THANK THEM THE MILITARY HAS
BEEN FANTASTIC WE'RE CLOSELY
HOSPITAL CITY HOSPITAL OPEN FOR
SURGERY. WE ONE AMERICANS TO
GET A GRIP THEY NEED ALL OF THE
GOVERNORS WE'VE SPOKEN WAS HAVE.
JUDGE DOWN WAS TO PREVENT THE
OVERFLOW. OF OUR SPILLS INTO
ALL THE DEMANDS CAUSED BY THE
GLOBAL PANDEMIC INCLUDING THE
VENTILATORS AT A PERMANENT
JUDGE YEAH. REALLY NIPPERT
OPTION ENTER COMPLETELY
UNSUSTAINABLE PRODUCE
DEBILITATING ECONOMIC FALL BACK
AND LEAD TO CATASTROPHIC PUBLIC
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES THERE ARE
TONS OF. YEAH WELL WE'VE SAY
POTENTIALLY MAKE USE OF LIVES
BY DOING THE INITIAL SHUT DOWN
BUT NOW WE'RE- VERY. THIS
DISEASE WE UNDERSTOOD. MAYBE
EVER FULLY UNDERSTAND IT BUT
WILL END UP WITH A QUEUE UP
WITH THERAPEUTICS WILL END WITH
A VACCINE. THREE ESCAPE THE
MASS SOCIAL DISTANCING PLOY
VIGOROUS HYGIENE WASH YOUR
HANDS EVERY CHANCE YOU WELL
SHELTERING HIGH RISK PATIENT.
WE EMPLOYED AMERICANS TO AVOID
PACKED LARS AND OTHER CREDIT
INDOOR GATHERINGS BE SAFE AND
SMART WE'RE SURGING TESTING
CAPACITY TO IDENTIFY AND
ISOLATE ISSUES INCLUDE THE
NUCLEAR TEST PLOT. TO NURSE AS
A GROUP. BEING VERY. RESPECTED
THING SPEAK NO ALL OF THE PRO
THAT WE'VE AT. WITH SOMEBODY SO
SADLY THEY WERE INFECTED SO
THAT ALL OF THE STAFF AND
RESIDENTS CAN BE ROUTINELY DID
IN ISOLATE. SURE MORE STRONGLY
AFFECTED THAN ANYBODY ELSE
THAT'S REALLY THE- HIGHER RISK.
A HIGHER RISK. THE FULL TABLE
ONCE INSURGENT THE JUST STINK
LAD FOR LABOR PEOPLE VISIT
THEIR LOVED ONES. EXECUTIVES
SUITE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE OUR
GOAL. IS MERELY TO MANAGE THE
PANDEMIC BUT TO END IF WE WANT
TO GET RID OF IT SOON AS WE GET.
AS WELL I GET IT C. MAIN. PRIOR
TO BACK CAN ARE THE FINALS OF
CLINICAL TRIALS THIS MONTH THIS
WAS ACHIEVED IN RECORD TIME IT
USED TO BE YEARS BEFORE OVER IT
LIKE WE ARE RIGHT. RATHER FILES
IN THE FILE. PRODUCING THE TOP
CAT ARE THAT THE FOR APPROVE
WERE BE OF IMMEDIATELY AND
LOGISTIC WE HAVE LETERRIER
DATING WE HAVE GREAT PEOPLE
JUST STICK MINUTE VERY PEOPLE.
WAIT SO THEY CAN JUST IT IN
RECORD TIME THAT'S WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN SO OUR MILITARY IS
ALL SET TO GO. WE BAXI. THERE
APPEAR. THIS IS THIS IS AT THE
FEET THE VIRUS ONCE AND FOR ALL
AND I'LL TAKE OF QUESTIONS
LIKE- I WILL SAY I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE STAFF THE
WHITE HOUSE STAFF. OR DOCTORS
HE WILL MOSTLY DID A LOT OF
VERY POSITIVE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING IT'S A- HI PAUL. HE
SHOULD HOW DO YOU GET CHINA BUT
IT DID ADDED THE WORLD AND
WORLD THE STUFF BUT WE'RE GOING
TO GET IT TAKEN. AND WE'RE
HELPING LOTS OF COUNTRY. FIRST
ONE. PRESS SAID TODAY THAT
SOMETIMES TAKE MORE THAN TEST
TODAY ONE. ALL WHAT I DIDN'T
ABOUT THAT ONE I DO TELL YOU
PROBABLY ARE OUT OF STATE THE-
THIS IN I DON'T HAVE ANY TIME
AT TWO TO ONE DAY BUT I COULD
SEE THAT HAVE. FORMER FOR TEST
IT WAS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
THE STATE SO THEY CAN DO MORE
TESTING AND YOU PROBABLY SAW
MICK MULVANEY THE OTHER. FIVE
SAID THAT DOT. COM TEST RESULTS
BACK THIS IS. AN EXCUSE. GIVEN
WHAT WE INDEPENDENT. WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH TEST IN THIS
COUNTRY NOW WHENEVER YOU WOULD
FAVOR MORE MONEY FOR TWO. WEEKS
MORE TESTED FARTHER BUT HE SAID
OF TEST. S. YOU MAY TAKE SLOW.
THE TO IS YOU KNOW A VERY QUICK
THAT. MINUTES AND FIFTY MINUTES
AS- THERE ARE FRANKLY THE WAY
THAT I'VE- MASS NUMBERS AND
THEN ARE GOING DOWN. AND WE GO
AN EXAMPLE THERE ARE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF KIDS BEING
MADE RIGHT NOW WE'LL GIVE YOU
FIFTEEN. AND A FIVE. BE ABLE
NUMBERS AND- RESIST ANOTHER.
ALSO A WHEN MASS NUMBER NUMBER
LIKE NOBODY THOUGHT POSSIBLE
BUT THOSE NUMBERS WILL BE
COMING DOWN AND I AGREE I THINK
IT'S A GOOD THING TO LOOK INTO.
ONE FOR TESTING. AND AGAIN
WE'RE LEADING THE WORLD I THINK
THE SECOND COUNTRY AT TWELVE
WORD WOULD BE OVER FIFTY
MILLION TEST SECOND CUT INDIA
TWELVE MILLION THEN YOU HAVE A
SEVEN MILLION TO MILLION FROM
MILLION. THAT WE HAD. BUT IF
THE IF THE DOT TO THE PROFESSOR
FEEL THAT EVEN THOUGH WE'RE THE
LEVEL THAT THEY HAVE A JOB FOR
US THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO DO
I'M OKAY WITH. RIGHT AT YES
PLEASE. I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
IN NOVEMBER IF YOU WANT EMERICA
PEOPLE TO JUDGE THIS DO YOU
WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
JUDGE YOU ON THE BALLOT IN THE-
THIS AMONG OTHER THINGS. THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL JUDGE US
ON THIS BUT THE JUDGES ON THE
ECONOMY THAT I CREATED THAT
ALREADY WORK IN A GROUP SETTING
RECORD. NUMBERS AS YOU KNOW.
I'M A VERY. HERE IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN STRONG THIRTEEN. GOOD FOR
THE FOURTH QUARTER BUT I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO BE A RECORD
YEAR AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE IN BUT I THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO BE A EXCLUDING THE IN
CUTTING WHICH- AVERAGE. TO THE
EXTENT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DELIVER. BUILDING THE MILITARY
HOW WE- A ON THE- WE BETTER
INSURANCE NOBODY THOUGHT THAT
WOULD BE PASS THAT'S BEEN MANY
DECADES BEEN TRYING TO GET TOYS.
RACE GO GET IT IF THEY HAVE TO
WAIT IN LINE TWO WEEK OR FIVE
WEEKS AND DAYS AND FRANKLY-
THAT'S BEEN A GREAT AND- I
THINK JUDGE WE- JUDGE IT ALL
THINGS DONE THANK. AND I THINK
WE CAN SAY THIS WAS SURELY IN
THE EVEN. IT IS THE FIRST
LETTERS. THE FIRST YEARS OF
BENSALEM MILLS ANY HAS
ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH WE WERE
FROM NJ TO HAVE SO MANY OF THE-
AND THEN THIS CAME IN AND THE-
HI THE PLAN. SHE TWO MILLION OF
LIVES WITH THAT AND NOW WE'VE
STARTED A MOP AND- I THINK WE
REALLY STARTED A VERY
SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT HI ON MY WRIST WOULD
SIMPLY DISAPPEAR. AND THAT IS
LIKELY TO GET WORSE BEFORE. IF
IT DOES GET WORSE IN THE
MERICAN NINE ARE YOU
RESPONSIBLE WELL THE VIRUS WILL
DISAPPEAR IT WILL DISAPPEAR I
THINK AT THE AISLE LIKE TO SAY
YOU KNOW THEIR WAY WHEN YOU
LOOK AT. TEAM VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S VERY VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS- I COULD SAY I'M
FULLY RESPONSIBLE BUT YOU KNOW
ONE DAY AT A VIRUS COME. HELLO
THE BORDERS THAT A LOT THINGS
ARE VERY. THOUSANDS OF LIVES
CLOSE THE BORDER NOBODY WANTED
TO DO WHAT I WANTED TO DO IT
WOULD CLOSE THE BORDER. ONE
PEOPLE COMING IN FROM INFECTED
CHINA. EARLY SHORTLY THEREAFTER
CLOSE THE BORDERS FROM COMING
IN FROM EUROPE THOSE WERE
TREMENDOUS MOVES WE WOULD. IF
ONE PERSONAL MONTHS LET'S SAY A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND WE
COULD HAVE DOUBLE TRIPLE
QUADRUPLE THAT NUMBER WE
DIDN'T. WE DID A LOT OF THINGS
WITH A LOT RIGHT WITH THE- SO.
IT'S JUST HAPPENED IT SHOULDN'T
HAVE HAPPENED CHINA SURE TO
STEP. THANK YOU PRESIDENT TRUMP
ON IF I COULD DO QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS- MY QUESTION IS WE
HAVE. TESTING PLATFORM THE
WHITE YES IT'S GREAT GETS. VERY
QUICKLY I DID YOU THAT IT WOULD
BE EASIER TO REOPEN AND RESTART
BUSINESSES WE COULD PRODUCE
MORE THIS IS YOUR TRYING TO
THAT'S GREAT QUESTION. TO THAT
SELF RULE SET TO TEST SEN YOU
KNOW GOES THROUGH THE MAIL DAY
COMES ANOTHER DAY NO MATTER HOW
THEY SEND THEM. IT'S A DAY IN A
DAY. TWO DAYS ALREADY WASTED
AND THERE HAVE BEEN SPENT BY
THE TIME YOU GET TICKETS THREE
OR FOUR DAYS IF THEY DO A GOOD
JOB WITH. GET THE ON SITE. MY
SECOND QUESTION. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THIS IS MAXWELL IS IN
ANCELOTTI ONE TO KNOW IF SHE'S
GOING TO TURN AND POWERFUL
PEOPLE I DON'T TALKED IN THE
PAST ABOUT PRINCE ANDREW AT.
SITES THE- OUR YOU SEE THAT I
DON'T KNOW I HAVEN'T REALLY
BEEN FOLLOWING IT TOO MUCH I
JUST WISH HER WELL FRANKLY I'VE
MET HER NEW JOB AT. SO I LIVED
IN PALM BEACH. I GUESS THEY
LIVED IN PALM BEACH- BUT I WISH
YOU WELL WHATEVER IT IS- I
DON'T KNOW THE SITUATION
PRINCESS. JUST DON'T KNOW AWARE
OF IT. I'M ONE OF KURTZ HOW
MUCH BELOW SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
ARE YOU WILLING TO GO AND YOU
SAID THAT THAT THE CONGRESS
COUNCIL BACKS FROM SO WHY DO WE-
WHAT THE ECONOMY. STRONG YES I
HAVE A VERY STRONG ECONOMY
ESPECIALLY IF SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I JUST SPOKE ABOUT
WORK- WE WANT TO HAVE PEOPLE
BACK AND GO BACK TO AS A PART
BASE FORCED INTO A WAY THAT
MAKING MORE MONEY. THE INTERNET
AND THE EMPLOYEE TO HAVE IT
RETURNED. BACK TO THAT WAS IT.
TO SEE WAS MADE I WAS AGAINST
ORIGINAL DECISION BUT THEY DID
THAT IT'S STILL WORKED OUT WELL
BECAUSE IT GAVE PEOPLE A
LIFELINE A REAL LIFELINE WE'RE
DOING IT AGAIN. TO BRING SEVEN.
AT THE WILL BE THE SAME BUT IT
BUT SMALL IN AMID SO THAT WE'RE
GONNA WANT TO GO BACK TO WORK
AS A POST AMID SO MUCH MONEY
THAT. YOU DON'T AFTER BUT WE
WERE R. J. WITH THEM. IF THAT.
IT'S TREMENDOUS. PROGRAM THE
WHOLE THING HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE HAVE.
PANDEMIC YET WE'RE SEEING
TREMENDOUS. JOBS I THINK THAT
THEY THOUGHT. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YES WE'RE IN THE MASS
WAS IN. IF THAT IS THE CASE.
ONE OF YOU EX DO IT WOULD I
NEED I'M I CARRY THEM WHEN I
HAVE TO GO WHITE HOUSE I WANTED
TO WALTER REED- AT THE MASS
GRAVE. THANK AND I WILL USE IT.
PROBLEM IT AND I'VE SAID THAT A
I SAY IF YOU CAN THE MASK WHEN
YOU CAN USE THE MASK IF YOU'RE-
CLOSE TO IT IF YOU'RE IN A
GROUP I WOULD. WHEN I'M
PROMINENT ELEVATE OUR PROTECT
THEM ALSO I PUT ON A MASK-
WE'LL HAVE. PROBLEMS THE MASKS
THIS WAY ANYTHING THAT
POTENTIALLY CAN HELP AND THAT'S
WE CAN POTENTIALLY HELP IS A
GOOD THING I HAVE NO KARAPET
WHERE IT USED. THE NUMBER OF
TIMES AND I CAN. THREE WEARING
A MASK AND THEN LAST EVENING WE
SAW YOU NOT WEARING THE MASK
YOUR HOTEL. I DON'T KNOW THE
HOTEL PRETTY FAR AWAY FROM
PEOPLE BUT I WOULD SAY THIS
I'VE EXPLAINED IT I THINK VERY
WELL. IF YOU'RE STICKING IT
WOULD ON THE ASK AND IF YOU'RE
NOT. WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE FULLY
TESTED I'VE BEEN TESTED
INTERIOR IN THE MASK. I'M
GETTING USED TO THE MASK AND
THE REASON IS. THINK OF
PATRIOTISM MAYBE. IT HELPS IT
HELPS NOW WE HAVE EXPERTS THAT
HAVE SAID IN THE RECENT PAST
THAT MASKS. ARE NECESSARY YOU
KNOW THAT. BUT THEY'VE IN MIND
THEY CHANGE THEIR MIND THAT'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME SO I WEAR IT
WHEN APPROPRIATE PLACE. THANK
YOU SIR ON. SURPRISE RANGE OF.
OVER ALL OF THIS MORE CORRECT
REALISTIC TELLING SOMEONE LOOK
AT IT THAT WAY THE SUDDEN
EMBRACE MASKS SOCIAL DISTANCING
THE- WITH THAT I MEAN OVER
FORTY EITHER ONE BUT CERTAINLY
SOCIAL DOES. I WANNA IT'S BEEN
SET. LEAVE HIS COMMON SENSE AND
LIKE TO SAY MAYBE MAKE IT A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER THE IDEA
THAT THE- PERHAPS. THEY GET.
THIS WELL IT'S FOR REAL WHEN
YOU TO TALK ABOUT INTO A LITTLE
FIRES PUT OUT HERE IN THERE.
NOW WE HAVE EMBERS FIRES THAT
WE HAVE BIG FIRES AND-
FORTUNATELY NOW FLORIDA IS TO.
IN A LITTLE TOUGH WE'RE IT A
BIG TOUGH POSITION- YOU HAVE A
GREAT UNDER THERE YOU HAVE A
GREAT GOVERNMENT. THIS YOU HAVE.
VERY SKILLED PEOPLE AND I
THEY'RE GOING TO HANDLE IT VERY
WELL- THE HOSPITAL COULD AS
CITIES ARE HOLDING. BUT TEXAS
IS A BIG STATE AND IT'S A WELL
RUN AND SO IS FLORIDA AND- I
THINK THEY'LL DO A VERY GOOD.
TELL YOU ABOUT THE ISSUE.
YESTERDAY STUDIES THESE
COMPANIES SINCE THE PROBLEM
RESULTS FOR ITS CORONAVIRUS
VACCINE CAN IN CHINA WERE FIRST
IN DEVELOPING THE BACK EVEN IF
IT WERE. THIS SHOULD BE WILLING
TO WORK WITH CHINA TO BRING US
WILL CHINESE BACK. WILLING TO
WORK WITH ANYBODY THAT'S GONNA
GET US A GOOD RESULT. CLOSE TO
THE VACCINE I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME VERY GOOD. RESULTS
WERE ALREADY IN TESTING NOBODY
THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE POSSIBLE
UNDER THE OLD. TWO YEARS BEFORE
YOU. ABOUT USING THE WORD. SO I
THINK WE'VE HAD A LOT OF AND
THE REASON WIJESINGHE THEY'VE
HAD GOOD RESULTS ON. THE
TESTING ALSO THE SAME. IS THAT
SAFE I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE SOMETHING OVER THE NEXT
FAIRLY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
MAYBE VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
HAVING TO DO WITH THERAPEUTIC
JAMES EVER IT WE'LL BE DOING
THESE WHAT. REST TALK ABOUT
SOMEBODY DOING WELL THE STOCK
MARKET HAD ANOTHER GOOD DAY I
THINK THEY HAVE A GOOD DAY
BECAUSE EIGHTY A LOT OF
POSITIVE THINGS HAPPENING ON
THIS FRONT TO MUCH. ON THE
BATTLE AGAINST THE CHILDREN
NINETEEN. GRETCHEN F